ANDREW GRANT: My
name's Andrew Grant.
I'm the technical
director for the MIT Game
Lab and sometime lecturer.
I've been playing games
pretty much all my life.
That's what my family does
when they get together.
And then when computers
started doing it too,
that's what I do with computers.
I went to the games
industry in 1994
working for Looking
Glass Technologies
and then I moved
out to California
to work for Dreamworks
Interactive.
And actually, all told, that
didn't last terribly long.
I burned out after
about five or six years
in the games industry.
And then I went to
be a solo programmer,
doing random contracts
and work-for-hire,
kind of like a gunslinger
from the Wild West for awhile.
But no matter what I do, I
keep getting dragged back
into the games industry.
I like making games.
It's what I want to do.
Right now I'm playing
a lot of things
I'm playing a lot of the
cooperative LEGO games
with my son.
He's four and we're playing
through LEGO Batman,
that sort of thing.
And we recently
started LEGO Lord
of the Rings, which has been
a bit of a challenge for him.
It's a much darker LEGO
game, oddly enough.
And so he'll say things
like is Boromir a bad guy?
And I'm like, well, that's hard.
Let me explain to
you, you're four.
He's confused.
Is Gollum a bad guy?
No, he's definitely
a bad guy, yeah.
But why is he going
with the hobbits?
Right, he's kind
of a good guy, too.
I don't know.
Anyway, it's a complicated
story for a four-year old.
And it's kind of fun.
I'm working on a number
things right now.
I'm working on a side project
with the astronomy department
on some software for them.
I'm working on an IOS port
of a game called Yomi.
And I'm also working
on a fractal tangram
independent game.
And with Rick, also,
at the lab, I'm
working on a massively
cooperative strategy game.
This semester we're trying
a couple new game engines.
We always try a couple
of new game engines.
But I always like to let the
students sink their teeth
into a couple of them and
then come back and tell us
what they found out.
There's a degree to which
I can do that myself,
but it really is
more useful, I think,
to get some people
with fresh eyes
to come in and try them out.
Usually they come
back and tell us
the old standbys are the
ones they want to go with.
We usually end up going
with Unity and Flixel
as our reliable ones.
But this year we're trying out
a new language hacks, which also
has a Flixel implementation.
And we're also
trying a game called
Phaser, which is used
by the Education Arcade.
So we really want to
get our teeth into that
and see how we like it.
I've always been interested
in artificial intelligence.
When I have a chance to sit
down and play with stuff,
I want to my computer
figure out how do things
that it couldn't do before.
That's a lot of fun.
We are in a really
interesting place,
I think, in games right now.
It used to be the case that
when I first started playing,
that there would be two or
three interesting games a year.
And you could play
them, and then you
waited very impatiently for
the next ones to come out.
And now we're in a place
where you cannot play all
the interesting games.
In fact, I can't even play all
the really interesting games.
There's just too many of them.
But in spite of that, I
still kind of want more.
One of the neat
things about games
is that there's a whole bunch
of different games you can make.
I feel like, a lot of times,
we get stuck on a couple types.
We don't necessarily need
another first-person shooter
that's super realistic
modern combat.
There are some good games there.
Don't get me wrong, but we
don't need five of them a year.
But what I'm really
looking forward
is seeing all the weird stuff,
the stuff that no one expects.
The new, crazy things, and
the more games get made,
the more crazy stuff gets made.
And I love that stuff.